zu sehen charakter kann ich auch andere
hochzieht und ich es
holosko zitiert er ist ein eigenwilliges
kind und fügt sich nicht gern
man darf ihn nicht befehlen wenn man ihn
nach seinem beruf fragt ist die antwort
klar ich will schiff seien seine
dominanz kraft ist stark er entwickelt
einen arbeits- von adis muss und ist
ehrgeizig und vereine also okay
dies ist die geschichte eines mannes der
sein leben auf den kopf stellt christian
jott jenny hier mit seiner mutter ist
musiker gründer des amts für ideen und
des jazzfestivals sankt moritz
jetzt will ein neuer gemeindepräsident
von sankt moritz werden krise gewählt
dann kriegen wir trainieren besonders
für macher war es ist bisher mit saison
frontier das wetter medizin und notieren
steigerung sogar nicht sang konfrontiert
aber st
das krisengebiet doch juristisch krise
gewählt um eine andere andere niveau
eigentlich gehört christian jenes leben
der musik er ist ehemaliger zeug
sängerknabe und hat sich in berlin zum
opern tenor ausgebildet jene macht sich
bereit für einen auftritt aus leo
wundergut eine seiner vielen rollen auf
der bühne lebens würdiger hoffen aber
auf hohem niveau
zwar sagen und mythen krippen kreis
gesicht sagen wie sie es um sie steht
und das gleich viel besser mit rekurs
figur als privatperson jenes gast beim
schweizerischen hauseigentümerverband wo
der direktor pensioniert wird
der im hive ausweis alles begriffe
vieles also einiges spricht das eine
oder das andere gewissermaßen auch zu
einem kleinen teil was ein bisschen
geprägt hat
in jenes leben jagt ein termin den
nächsten kam es auftritte ende teilen
die musikern den flughafen zum nächsten
termin in hamburg nicht mehr
konzentriert und bin jetzt die sache ich
möchte wie es auch fonds erteilt -
schlag auf schlag
aber das spülmittel ganzen region sind
computers blöd sind soll nicht schafft
wird will ich die neueste infos
religiöser führt moderation erhöht das
nennt man ist die mails checken
ich glaube passiert und kann sich völlig
unterschiedlich während daheim die er
schon nach durchgang und dann kanzlei
wegen traktiert spontanität und durch
produkte spontan die aktualität die
aktualität und spontan reservist alte
figur mit alter schlager und alte musik
tochter
selber musik machen war ja nie aber bald
zu wenig und so gründete er vor elf
jahren sein eigenes jazzfestival in
sankt moritz
dort lebt der temporär im umgebauten
olympiastadion von rom sachs dem
künstler und sohn von gunter sachs in
einer wg yen ist geschieden und vater
zweier kinder
sachs ist nur einer von vielen die yeni
als talentierter netzwerker für seine
ideen einsparen kann
zusammen verpflichten sie hochkarätige
künstler und so hat sich das festival in
kurzer zeit einen exzellenten ruf
geschaffen die künste unterland glaube
ich vergisst dass jetzt alle ein begriff
und die wand kern danach hoch und die
wisse die kommt in die triste landschaft
die habe den in intime rahmen in des
familiäres umfeld wo sie oft nur werdet
mit wärme und mit eritrea konzerthalle
wo das zack zack und start nur ums geld
ja das gold geht ja das ist wirklich das
soll warnt dutt kultur blüte der
sogenannte dracula club ist noch immer
das herz des festivals umfasst nur 150
zuschauern am letzten konzert dieses
sommers spielt der deutsche entertainer
helge schneider
[Applaus]
[Musik]
neben diesen konzerten organisiert juni
weitere in hotels unter freiem himmel
oder im hallenbad mit bis zu 3000
zuschauern ein enormer aufwand ein
ständiger kampf von bewilligungen und
gegen die langsamen mühlen der politik
zwar versprüht moritz gegen aussen noch
immer viel glamour
aber in der realität herrscht stagnation
und so kommt ja nicht zum schluss er
müsste ganz st moritz übernehmen mit
einer sprengkandidat uhr als parteiloser
für das gemeindepräsidium zwei tage nach
ende des festivals übte die bekanntgabe
seiner kandidatur mit freunden und
beratern finanziert von der kampagne ist
es so fasste der fraktur froh im moment
ist die kampagne und sozialen selber
finanzieren muss eigenbetrieb das
investment in die ganze geschichte
das ist nie fertig geld der grund die
macher bezogen gesamt durften nicht mit
begeisterung reddig sich hat möchte dass
die data wodurch natürlich unabhängig
foto notizen selbst vom stuhl aber die
partystimmung die stewards abgekommen
und wirtschaft liter
ich bin nämlich fremde texte gut
angenommen thema dir überlegen aber am
schluss dann enthält
die eigner und ideal standard poor s das
großartige rede gehört man die kirchen
als die politik ist mühsam ich noch ein
arbeitskollege schritt das lied i mühsam
ich noch ein abend ist hell musik machen
wir sagen ich noch eine aber dieses
festivals an friede jetzt für die
bühnenshow ist prozent tricks die arbeit
am schreibtisch mit blutprobe und so
weiter und so fort
dass ich immer wenn sie so locker vom
hocker und improvisiert wird das bedarf
für eine verdammt gute vorbereitung aber
ich glaube der moment wenn sie aber
lokal situation kann man wahnsinnig war
vorbereitet sind
das ist bin improvisieren so dass ich
auf die bühne so dass scheiße so und das
ist vermutlich eine politik also noch
ist alles vertraulich selbst jenes enge
freunde sind nicht eingeweiht
wie würde sich rolf sachs juni rein
theoretisch in der politik vorstellen
politik wird in sehr zermürbend
er glaubt geht es gleich und es ist
einfach obwohl er an versicherern
beamten ist in der politik ist es
einfach sehr oft so man muss so viel
kompromiss liga das mag ein richtig kurz
pures produkt das bringt und da muss man
ganz speziell gebaut sie anders machen
und bharat sie der ganze kontroverse
positionen und eine abschnitts mache und
er glaubt dass für tittling
als kind einer linken musiklehrerin wie
er sagt und eines bürgerlichen
professors und obersten wächst jene mit
klassischer musik und jazz auf
aber jene kann mehr aus singen schon als
teenager organisiert der ds jazzkonzerte
mit 18 ist es bereits eine reihe mit
dutzenden von veranstaltungen
das programm
jene sätze verrückte idee zum beispiel
mit bäumen in der kirche zürich witikon
und parkt sie durch realisierbar
das kleben zufällig den traumhaften und
findet fertig gestellte und motive hat
und danach noch fertig machen
[Musik]
und nun lässt jene an einer
pressekonferenz die bombe in sankt
moritz platzen
es ist der tag seines vierzigsten
geburtstags bei der letzten wahl für den
gemeindepräsidenten hat ein drittel der
stimmenden leer eingelegt ein ausdruck
von unzufriedenheit und jetzt soll der
amtierende nach acht jahren im kommt
nochmals ohne gegenkandidaten
durchgewunken werden so nicht sagt sich
jene mit royaler dfds die kaffee im
zweiten satz nicht trinken
es gibt dass er noch mutige wüste zwei
kandidaten für das präsidium versandt
worden
und wo bin ich überaus schon gelingt als
die journalisten die medienkonferenz
verlassen hängt bereits überall in sankt
moritz große plakate sieben wochen vor
der wahl eine neue ausgangslage doch
viele fühlen sich von janis kecken
wahlkampf angesprochen nimmt kein blatt
vor dem mund redet als wäre noch immer
leo wundergut und erwischt den
amtsinhaber auf dem falschen fuß wie
viele schlaflose nächte dmkg schlaflose
nacht ist vielleicht der falsche
ausdruck
ich habe sich enke gemacht was bewegt
sie richtigen untergrund herzlich erhält
man fehler gemacht aber das macht mit
christian i
sie gelten dort als ideal ich als mutig
sie genießen respekt sind ein motivator
sie sind direkt männliche arrogant
neuerdings aber mutig und übermütig und
sind naiv was das politische leben
betrifft ganze täter beschrieben findet
an dem dort haben soll
gehts sachen
[Applaus]
april zeigen die zürichsee zeitung vom
letzten jahr und den handelsmarkt als
ideologie und händler die zeit reist als
favorit ist am arsch die reaktionen
lassen nicht lange auf sich warten
das politische establishment von sankt
moritz schießt in leserbriefen aus allen
rohren gegen jene sofort ist mario
sahlis politiker und ehemalige hauptmann
der kantonspolizei und das handy kann
die wertigkeit problem aber die erste
interview gläsern industries wohnen wo
sie politik als saustall deklariert als
kinder das schulzimmer und dem vor allem
auch dass er ein präsident für die junge
also für die und 70 jähriger ist heute
klar so definiert dass legale hofgang
sei so sogar das lied ein sieg natürlich
hunger oder das ist das ist falsch
das erstaunen als als provokation
probiert's vorstand
doch jene trifft wunde punkte projekte
für die leerstände reithalle kommen
nicht vom fleck
angebote für die jungen sind rar
geworden das letzte kino geschlossen
abends herrscht tote hose in den gassen
die einzige top destination verliert
mehr logiernächte aus nachbardörfern
jene kommt unter beschuss als seine
plakate werden versprechen dann entsteht
eine gegenbewegung die jungen formieren
sich und engagieren sich mit wahl
optionen
doch der aktuelle gemeindepräsident
macht auch vieles richtig
die finanznot eingriff und die steuern
sind tief
also die gegen reben die begriffe nicht
das selbe arbeit der kunterbunte gemeint
polizei und der feuerwehr und dem
öffentlichen bus oder bahn seelischen
rektoren das problem ist dass das dorf
seelisches stirbt oder muss sterben ist
dass das ist dunkel reise gewesen das
heißt lud darum dunkel mit dem bezug ist
seelenarbeit sieben wochen nach
bekanntgabe der kandidatur sonntagmorgen
der tag der wahl seit ein paar minuten
sind die urnen geschlossen
[Musik]
schärfe regie sprache juni wartet darauf
dass die gemeindekanzlei den beiden
kandidaten das ergebnis der wahl per sms
mit dem siegel iberischen absolutes mail
829 christian 824 7 809 es findet ein
zweiter wahlgang statt allen noch einen
schönen sonntag
[Musik]
trotz 70 prozent stimmbeteiligung wie
sich jenen die noch nicht freuen und der
parteilose sigi asprion ist ernüchtert
gewisse populismus ich sicher die weg
sehen wenn wir die luft reckten ist aber
als würde sie das machen ja sina sina
544 punkten
nachts kann es besser sind zwar hoch
aber es sind doch keine lösung hin wird
und die eigentlich bis jetzt bis 7 jetzt
geben die ns gegner ausschalten inserate
die lokal parteien schlagen sich auf die
seite von sigi asprion bis zum schluss
weiß niemand wer die nase vorn haben
wird am tag der entscheidung trifft sich
jene mit dem engsten kreis hinter
künstler wg erneutes warten auf das sms
[Musik]
sehen wir jetzt sehr stutzig gemacht
traumata des morgens richtig lieber
christian wo sich die spur
christian liebe sie hier die resultate
vom zweiten wahlgang richtigen 800 4
1-sieger 822 gratulieren richter hat das
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenig muss ich noch ein bisschen was
gerade den eindruck ja
was brächte so muss man auch die türkei
sowie das wort erklären
also ich uns noch weniger ruft pisten
sind unter anderem zuständig fürs
militär
das geht dann die polizei eine andere
vorstände aufgabe bis jetzt nötig ihre
kernkompetenz krise das ist dann weiter
geht's michael kompetent ich glaube ich
glaube muss vor allem aber muss vor
allem gute generalist sie und nicht
alles im detail kenne und und im
überblick paul tom frauenfußballs weiß
gab das rheinische
guten morgen danke vielmals und alles
ist nein noch nicht aber ich würd ich
würde gerne schnell also bei sturm reißt
seine die 1&1 oder so viel ist sicher
dass man sich brinkmann zusammen ist das
gut
ok alles liebe
danke siegi
ganz einfach überhaupt nicht das ist was
wir am meisten beschäftige thema
dass politik ja wahrscheinlich ist ein
handlicher halt nicht ganz einfach aber
was am anfang kaum jemand gedacht hätte
ist passiert ab dem ersten januar 2009
10 steht christian häni an der spitze
von sankt moritz und trägt die volle
verantwortung
ich freue mich einfach nur zum schluss
quasi vor dem porträt wir stark
christoph drop stellen
nach zehn jahren empfehlen was machen
[Gelächter]
wenig wahrscheinlich aber ich fahre gern
für android ist grund stand ist er
inhaber sind verantwortet sie immer und
sich immer immer bis jetzt immer gut
immer weniger vertrauen und vertrauen
auf die er für andere